folks on friday we did something really
cool here at daily wire we released our
first
major motion picture run hide fight
stars isabelle may and thomas jane
it is an edge of your seat thriller it's
awesome it's r rated edgy
gritty complex exciting it's it's the
stuff that you want in a movie you would
watch it whether you're conservative
or not conservative and we've had
amazing engagement people are loving
the film for those of you who have
watched and posted about it i've really
enjoyed seeing your comments and
reactions our brand is building and we
are
so excited to have new members in the
daily wear community we cannot wait
to make more entertainment like run hide
fight
so here's the question that we've been
getting a lot from left right and center
why are a bunch of folks who create
podcasts and internet news
releasing an action-packed thrill ride
of a movie well the answer is because we
are in the middle of a culture war
okay the fact of the matter is that the
culture is dominated by the left all the
cultural institutions and it's not just
that hollywood is dominated by the left
that their content caters
almost solely to the left you'll have a
tentpole flick every so often that
really brings in the big bucks
but most of their low-level content is
replete with leftist messaging
and the reality again is that the
critics help exacerbate this problem if
you check out the gap on rotten tomatoes
between what the critics think and what
the audience thinks
it's often quite wide and usually where
the movies are most
political so you need an alternative you
need a place to go
where you can see entertainment that is
not going to deliberately offend your
values
where you can see a movie that is
actually going to side with you
and against a lot of left-wing tropes
about the united states the gap has been
emerging in real time between hollywood
and the rest of the united states
hollywood made atomic blonde which was
an attempt to respond to james bond by
basically just making james bond a woman
very often the critics are just judging
movies almost solely based on politics
good example the jordan peel movie us
now the movie is like
okay it's not a great movie it's
certainly not as good as get out but
they decided universally that it was
very important for you to watch it
because it had super important messages
so all the reviews said things like
well the movie doesn't meet the high
standards who get out it's also a super
duper important movie that you must see
all of america must see this movie why
well because of the messages
of us which is all about income
inequality and racial inequality
and all of jordan peel's usual sort of
leftist messages you see the same thing
even with movies like wonder woman 1984
when wonder woman 1984
came out audiences basically looked at
when this is not good except for the
critics
we're like you know what sure it's not a
really good movie but it's so feminist
it's filled with just amazing girl power
ideals okay the the fact is that
hollywood is constantly making
entertainment that is designed to not
only oppose your principles but then
they are praising it to the skies and
they do something else too they do
something else that's worthy of known
if you don't like their movies then the
problem is you it is not hollywood
you are now toxic fandom so if you
watched star wars last jedi and you
thought that rose was a super boring
character
because let's face it rose is a super
boring character or if you thought last
jedi is just not a very good film
it was because you're a toxic fan who
could not handle the wonders
of rhian johnson's completely failed
reimagining of the star wars universe
if you watch captain marvel and you're
like you know this movie it's not
amazing it's not like horrible but it's
not amazing the media treated you as
though you're a toxic fan if you looked
at ghostbusters and it was female
ghostbusters lady ghostbusters and he
said this movie just isn't very good
then the claim by the media was that you
were a member of the toxic phantom you
just didn't understand the depths
of female woke ghostbusters well what
are you to do i mean as a person who
enjoys entertainment what are you to do
we can yell at netflix we can yell at
apple tv we can yell at espn
but most of us still subscribe to one of
those services but one thing that you've
been doing is you've been tuning out
many conservatives cancel their netflix
subscriptions over the cuties
controversy cuties of course was a movie
from france that seemed to glorify
pedophilia i mean it had all of these uh
kind of insanely graphic shots of young
girls dancing in extraordinarily
inappropriate ways hashtag cancel
netflix was in the top trending spot on
twitter
on september 10th the day after the
release of the film two days later
netflix's cancellation rate in the
united states jumped nearly eight times
higher
than the average daily levels recorded
in august of 2020
reaching a multi-year high a lot of
people still are subscribing to netflix
but a lot of people drop netflix after
cuties
a lot of folks in the sports world have
decided that they are no longer going to
be participating
in viewing sports i'm one of those
people i'm a huge sports fan
but if you look at the numbers on espn
since 2013
they've declined markedly people have
been cutting the cord like crazy i
watch baseball i watch basketball i
watch football but this season i didn't
watch a minute of any of them because
they decided in the middle of the black
lives matter protest to simply mirror a
bunch of untruths about the united
states
and america's systemic racism the idea
was that if you didn't really want to
see equality throwing up an alley-oop
for black lives matter that somehow you
were a racist they allowed all these
woke messages to take over
the entire sport and corrupt the sports
that you weren't actually watching
sports you are now watching msnbc with a
little bit of basketball in between
forbes reported that nba playoff ratings
have been slipping as fans grumble the
league has become too political the
miami herald study reveals reasons for
enormous drop in sports viewership
including political dynamic they say 70
of republicans said they are less likely
to watch live sports because of athlete
calls for racial
justice well no it's not because of
athletes calls for racial justice it's
because athletes
have been kneeling for the national
anthem suggesting that america is
systemically racist and that all
inequalities
are chalked up to inequities that the
police are bad and racist across the
board
well the reality is that the right we
can tune out
but it's not enough to tune out we have
to offer alternatives the amount of time
that people spend
engaging with entertainment content on
average dwarfs the amount of time they
spend engaging with overtly political
content there's a reason that millions
of people believe lies about
conservatives there's a reason millions
of people believe lies
about america there's a reason that
people look at you if you don't like
these movies as though you're a bad
person they've been trained to do so by
a culture that despises conservatives
you can see it in nearly every film you
can see it in virtually all tv
it is it is a blanket statement about
you hollywood is they
they won't cater to you most obviously
when they decided that hillbilly elegy
was a terrible terrible film because it
took seriously the concerns
of poor white people so here's the thing
we need alternatives
it's not enough to just disengage it's
not enough to just turn off the tv
you need some place to go the human
brain wants narrative the human brain
wants to watch competition we want
engagement
and we need people who aren't political
to engage with different sorts of
content
rather than disengaging entirely we need
to give people a different option
and so here's what daily wire is
planning daily wire will in 2021 be
jumping into the world of entertainment
content we're going to start by putting
our stamp on tv and movies we'll make
edgy and entertaining films that aren't
trying to brainwash you
every step of the way the entertainment
content is gonna range from comedies and
dramas that take you seriously and don't
take advantage of your viewership to
promote
leftist causes okay you're not gonna be
hit over the head with either right wing
or left-wing
causes the way that tv usually does and
the fact is that if you've watched even
a single episode of snl it is basically
just at this point jacob magazine with a
couple of punch lines thrown in
a conservative who became the voice of a
generation voice of generation dvd
with a powerful message powerful message
tbd
that's the man from long ago who stood
up to donald trump
looks just like him at dvd close above
head dbd it's time to blow up the death
star that is the left-wing monopoly on
entertainment and to provide a
replacement for your bucks so that
you're not paying the people who want to
see your values
disappear we don't just want to be
producing entertainment that caters to
your values we want it to be provocative
we want to compete for the most
important audience in the entertainment
sphere young adults the films are going
to be gritty
they'll be violent we plan to push the
boundaries because guess what that's
what people watch the vast majority of
conservatives actually want to watch the
same kind of stuff everybody else wants
to watch they just don't want to be
insulted in the process
well we are going to be dedicated to
making that kind of content
our content may offend some of the
people in our audience we can't win the
culture war
if we're not competing for the people we
are attempting to reach
it's not going to help to make a
conservative more conservative we need
to make moderates
more conservative we need to take
liberals and we need to allow them to
see a conservative
point of view through a medium that is
going to attract them and isn't going to
repel them well this sunday
you can watch me talk about this with
dallas sonia he's producer of run hide
fight he creates content from this point
of view too
that's why we joined forces on run hide
fight so i'm excited about 2021 i think
you should be too conservative is
getting into the entertainment space
it's something conservatives have talked
about for a very very long time we've
expended hundreds of millions of dollars
on white papers from think tanks we've
expended billions of dollars
on elections but until we engage in the
culture we're just going to keep losing
my mentor andrew breitbart he used to
say the culture is upstream of politics
if we never engage in the culture war
how do we expect to win the political
wars we are getting involved we want you
to be
involved too we need your help this
content is not exactly cheap to produce
we need your help to let the word out
let people know that you enjoyed run
hide fight and that you want to get
engaged
with the culture we plan to compete in
every arena because the left
has spent the last 50 years taking over
nearly every institution in american
life
the only way that we're going to be
victorious is if we push back all at
once in every
perceivable area and entertainment is
just the first step
so we hope you'll join us over at
dailywire.com and join the fight for the
culture